joining me here now in his fifth year in
the national football league just made
his third pro bowl he's an all-pro
player getting set to try and bring
another curtain down on the pittsburgh
steelers for the cleveland browns the
all-world miles garrett here on the rich
eisen show and westwood one good to see
you miles garrett
pleasure to be on with you i appreciate
that uh how you feeling how's it going
for you right now i'm pretty good i'm
looking forward to it okay very good um
how much do you hear it from the crowd
when you go to pittsburgh miles just
jump in with both feet here
uh i don't have one
i really haven't i don't think
we've got a packed house since uh cover
started okay
so
you're getting ready to go to this game
and um
when you take the field uh in a game
like this walk me through your mindset
as you get ready
for it miles you and i have never really
talked before but
how do you get ready for a game like
this mentally
i mean
before that's my routine never changes
you know i'm kind of just
i'm trying to find my zone listening
some music and watching some some videos
that motivate me okay
what videos motivate you
i watch uh once a lot basketball videos
mike kobe uh lebron
i watch ali
hagler
uh bruce smith
uh moss
uh reggie white
lt
and just watching them
do their thing motivates you how like
how does that work
miles i just know that i wanted to be on
that that level of greatness you know
doing you know making big plays and and
big uh big moments like uh they they
have and they they consistently did you
know just you know trying to just act
myself up thinking that no i'm on that
level i can do things like that all i
have to do is i'll just play like i have
interesting and do you watch them in the
locker room before the game or your you
turn off and you do your own thing on on
game day before you get out there
on game day that's that's what i do i
listen to music i have time now to have
them i'm watching
one of them
interesting miles garrett here prior to
monday night football and for the for
the cleveland browns this season um
what would you attest the
i guess the ups and downs to is it just
injuries what is it would you say
miles for this year
for the browns
i mean kobe really took a toll on us and
that i mean that didn't help what was
what's going on during the season but uh
you can't really blame our injuries not
every team has a has to deal with
injuries i think it's just you know we
needed to play more complimentary
whether it's on defense no russian
coverage or an offense to defense you
know just you know countering off of
them whether they scored we make a stop
or they don't score and uh you know we
don't get a stop no we have to find a
way to
know when they're doing well we have to
do well they're they're not doing well
well then we have we have to you know
get the ball back to them and and help
them get their their mojo back and i i
think
you know there were times where there
were just lols whether it was in games
or for for multiple games where we we uh
we didn't play complimentary football
and so this weekend this monday night
game what's at stake is obviously the
playoffs maybe your division and then
did i hear you say that you're looking
forward to making sure this is ben
roethlisberger's last
game at heinz field did i overhear you
say something like that this week miles
garrett
i don't think i said it but uh i sure i
i saw it and uh
i didn't think it was a bad quote you
know hearing it
but i just want to make sure i did
hear that that that that is your
intention
correct
of course i mean
i didn't say it but that is my intention
you did not say it so how did i get it
how did that get ascribed to you i don't
understand
i'm not sure at least i don't recall
saying i don't think i talked to anybody
who would uh who would put that out but
okay i i don't disagree i would love for
this to be his as his last one game and
we can send them off with the with the l
that would be perfect
see so you did say
right here i guess uh in this
conversation and you know i don't i
don't blame you i mean like that's that
would be your intention to do that and
you guys
did it last year as well so
is there a specific you know beating the
steelers make it
even more special for you guys
in cleveland you yourself
i mean they have no love for us and we
don't we don't really have love for them
as a as a city so you know this is a
rivalry that i heard about as soon as i
got onto the team
so for to have to go through them for a
playoff spot is i think it's poetic
miles garrett before monday night
football here in week 17. um
what's your front row seat to watching
baker mayfield work tell me something
that
uh about him that folks might not know
miles guard
for you
ah
he puts it all on himself i don't know
that don't people really when you see
that know whether
it's a end of a drive or you know
why we were slipping you know whatever
whatever happens he's really thinking
that no he could he could have done
something better right there or whether
he got three points he could have got
six
and uh he had to find a path find a way
to get better whether it's on a certain
play drive or during the game you know
he he's
very cerebral in in the fact that he he
wants to be better and how he's trying
to like work through this you know
almost every time he he turns the page
but he's like well how come how can we
make this this next one better how can i
how can i improve
does he get a bad rap do you think
uh i think so i think he gets a bad rap
i mean
in a day
no sometimes we have lows i'm in a i'm
gonna a slump right now i haven't had a
sack in two games
and i mean he had a bad game last game
at the end of the day he turned around
and have four touchdowns
and oh that's that's sometimes the name
of the game you just gotta be able to
bounce back do you think you're in a
slump right now
yeah well in my eyes mine's i haven't
i've had a sack i haven't been as
dominate or disruptive
as i want to be and uh you know a slump
to me is is not performing up to my
standard who would you name defensive
player of the year removing yourself
from the equation
miles garrett
removing myself
made you think
i like that
i would
probably say
micah
he's doing this off the charts right
what he's doing would you say yes just
because he's doing it in all he's doing
it in multiple but this i can't say all
positions but you know as far as rushing
coverage
you know he's you know he was at bb one
time i mean the guys he's a
he's an athlete and he's he's a baller
and there exists and they put him in so
it's it's it's fun to watch him play
just because
he he has great great pursuit great
energy a great motor and he has he has a
skill semester and plus you you would
know what it's like to go from one level
to the other five years ago you did that
and um that can't be simple to go from
college to the pros and start balling
out like that i imagine as well right
you say oh
depends i mean he he fell into
a pretty good situation you know a lot
of older guys around him helping
help him grow help him you know find
find himself in the league whether it
was off the field or
trying to to maintain his his schedule
and i think he he kind of fell in to a
spot where he just
he just had to focus on football he had
some he had some great mentors with
with uh lawrence and uh
a couple of those other no d-linemen up
there and and linebacker so i think i
think he's in a good spot and uh
i mean right now it's coming coming very
easy too
are you friendly with any other of the
guys like in the in the league aaron
donald do you have any relationship with
him or anybody else at your position
miles uh
danielle hunter
uh max crosby
a couple of guys but uh uh
i feel like
i'm friendly with a lot of d linemen not
too many quarterback for some reason
[Laughter]
for some reason
see i i imagine you you have to have
that mentality that you enjoy hitting
them and disrupting them and do you do
you talk to them when you
you disrupt them and do something miles
are you a talker
out there miles garrett
uh
slightly like uh what
i remember i hit joe burrow and uh but i
hit them and like i was i was picking
them up i said uh
good to see you joe it was like great
hit miles good to see you
or i'll say god bless or it was just
small stuff i
nothing nothing derogative or rude i'm
just
i'm just uh
just catching up after a while i have no
i haven't seen some of these
quarterbacks in a while just want to say
hello so yeah because when you say good
to see you joe um
i don't know if you really mean that you
know what i mean like it doesn't seem
too genuine
i am glad to see him i'm glad to see him
when i get to hit him i get to put him
on my my graveyard my stat sheet and
his his mother's a lovely woman she's
from my mom it's just great to see him
are you serious i didn't know that i had
no idea about that so your graveyard
where where is that right now where
where do you put all those pieces
non-halloween time miles where are they
i'm got a nice storage spot
away from the house okay
so and then you you take notes and
who makes sure that it's accurate that
your graveyard is accurate
we'll make sure that
i had a friend that took notes
and just made sure
you know i had the amount of sacks and
amount of people that uh
i needed to
and uh
you know i was trying to do like notice
a couple of guys i wanted to get this
season on i already got and something
like that
and then no bruce smith came out and did
every single person he sacked that was
just made me feel so terrible
that's all right miles you're just
getting started man and you're off to a
hell of a start after five years and
he's got 200. you know i mean like so
that's something to shoot for that's why
you watch his videos it had to be cool
that he saw that and you inspired him to
do that that had to be pretty cool for
you though right absolutely that that i
i made him get up and and do something
like that because you know he's i mean
he's one of the best ever the fact that
he's even paying attention to me it's
blessed that is pretty cool miles
garrett have a great monday night
football have a great rest of your
season let's catch up down the line i
really appreciate your time it's been
fun yes i appreciate you let's do this
more often that's miles garrett right
here on the rich eisen show
hey you watched all the way to the end
thanks for that watch more right here